привіт мамуля
Привіт
матір Тетяни 69-річну пенсіонерку
Валентину Іванівну сень родичі змогли
поховати тут на місцевому кладовищі лише
через кілька тижнів після її смерті
російські окупанти розстріляли її 25
березня 2022 року на власному подвір’ї
де вона пролежала до моменту деокупації
все все окупатися мама була в шарфики
в цьому
це одне що залишилося від неї
її шарф
ще молода енергійна жіночка була
не найшла їм загрозу вони просто
позбавили її життя
і нас тим самим втратився сенс життя
донька Тетяна першітижні окупації
пережила поруч з мамою однак у дині і
вбивства не була поруч напередодні вона
евакуювалася з дитиною до Києва мама
Валентина їхати не захотіла те що
сталося з пенсіонеркою бачили сусіди
жінки ходила по воду А ходила по воду
Там де Ну якраз стояли солдати заїхали
ці солдати
і почали просто стріляти просто так
стріляти вони були злі а в цей момент
мама була десь тут вона розмовляла по
телефону і вона видно злякалась вона
почала бігти і вони б не почали стріляти
Вони почали стріляти но вони не попадали
а не забігла додому ось
ще встигла за собою закрити двері і її
через двері не встигла пуля через цю
дірку маму вбили куля влучила вона
печінку было Мама просто кров'ю вона
стекла кров'ю через рік після вбивства
матері Тетяна ще жодного разу не була на
допиті у слідчих у квітні 2022 покази
давав лише її син який особисто ховав
бабусю і першим знайшов і мертвою коли в
місто зайшли ЗСУ нам не телефонували Ну
і нічого а я даже не знаю чи ну є справа
батька Сергія Олександра яремича росіяни
теж були у той день 25 березня незадовго
до деокупації Київщини він розносив
місце в мабуть і харчі та воду неподалік
російських блокпостів візьміть його
приятелів на початку місяця розстріляли
на цьому місці по вулиці яблунській
батька через два тижні після них так
само неподалік після обшуків у будинку
коли військовий зашли вже безпосередньо
на подвір'я де неподалік знаходився Мій
батько вони побачили що окрім чотирьох
чоловіків є ще п'ятий
покликали його і позабирали казали
пройти трошки далі
в лісочок так за кінець вулиці
прозвучало спочатку один постріл далі
три Ну і тиша до сьогодні син Олександра
протягом року щомісяця дзвонив
правоохоронцям аби з'ясувати статус
вправи про вбивство батька втім спершу
довго тривала ексгумація та звір доказів
а через кілька місяців поміняли слідчого
лише нещодавно Сергія відбувся перший
допит повільно але все ж таки прогрес є
тобто вони
звітують Що вони зробили
Кажуть який процес наступний але наразі
теж Ну це довготривалий процес це
сумніваюсь що навіть через рік
закінчиться
за минулий рік розповідає заступник
керівника Київської обласної прокуратури
слідчі СБУ здійснили повне обстеження до
окупованої території регіону провели
ексгумації та зібрали усі докази щодо
наявних справ випадки воєнних злочинів
зокрема фізичної наруги над цивільним
населенням нарахували майже 11 тисяч
щодо них вже відкрито понад 7 тисяч
кримінальних проваджень підозрюваних 118
а заочно перед судом постали 50 осіб з
них 4 ом винесено вироки допомагали
слідчим зі збором такої кількості даних
проводінні злочини волонтери у складі
організованих груп з документування
причина тривалого слідства пояснюють в
обласній прокуратурі комплексна складно
встановити осіб злочинців та неможливо
затримати таких людей фізично наразі ми
робимо роботу яка потребує необхідну для
суспільства і для того щоб за кожний
злочин у нас должна быть забрана
відповідна доказову базу да деяка час
людей буде у нас притягнута заочно а
інша частина вона буде буде притягнута
до відповідальності після нашої Перемоги
нічого не буде в цьому році я думаю ми
ще отримую велику кількість вироків
після цього людина буде знаходяться в
міжнародному розшуку і
України підписано доволі велика
кількість міжнародних правових угод щодо
видачі злочинців
крім розслідувань у самій Україні нині
понад 20 країн світу відкрили в межах
свого національного законодавства
провадження щодо воєнних злочинів Росії
окремим напрямком слідства є провадження
щодо злочинів з боку вищого політичного
керівництва РФ за 642 підозрюваних серед
яких очільник російського Міноборони
генштабу розвідки депутати держдуми
центру банку нещодавно ордери на арешт
президента Володимира Путіна та
уповноваженої з прав дитини в Росії
Марії Львова і білової видав міжнародний
кримінальний суд в гаазі це кажуть
правники Лише початок але вже вагомий
крок у притягненні злочинців до
відповідальності цей ордер має
надзвичайно велике значення не тільки
тому що це фактично
визнання наявності доказів злочину
а ще й тому що цей ордер має з одного
боку стримуючи такий запобіжний Фактор
оцінка цих дій може трансформуватися і
вони можуть бути перекваліфіковані
зокрема на геноцид На даному етапі
правники кандидат юридичних наук Дениса
заро вбачає кілька напрямків для
українського та міжнародного слідства
перший створення в Україні окремої
спеціальної групи яка буде займатися
розслідуванням воєнних злочинів вчинених
російськими солдатами інший напрямок
міжнародне доведення факту геноциду щодо
українського народу з боку РФ для цього
важливої ратифікації Римського статуту
міжнародного кримінального суду зауважує
правник адже це дозволить поширити
юрисдикцію цього суду на території
України і розглядати справи щодо
злочинів скоєних тут поки що в гаазькому
суді підписали угоду про створення офісу
прокурора МКС в Україні тим часом родичі
вбитих цивільних унаслідок окупації з
боку РФ поки не мають офіційного статусу
а окремі докази та свідчення не
закріплені юридично без спеціальних
рішень суду практики не існує це вперше
по суті кажучи така ситуація 100%
результат встановлений бути не може хоча
б тому що
мені видається нереалістичним встановити
абсолютно всіх людей які вчиняли від
найменшого будемо так говорити в лапках
е-е злочину до до всіх причетних до
припустимо геноциду української нації
треба мати чітку стратегію
і розуміти які посягання будуть
розслідуватись суто в межах
національного кримінального
процесуального законодавства А які все ж
таки мають бути передані на розгляд
міжнародного кримінального суду
ця улица стала называться дорогою смерті
на цій вулиці вбивали людей без разбору
Костянтин гудаускас волонтер з
Казахстану який На власні очі бачив
трупи цивільних вбитих у Бучі на вулиці
яблунській Під час окупації у ті дні рік
тому він як волонтер евакуйовував мирних
жителів звідси до Києва після деокупації
Костянтин особисто долучився
додокументування злочинів росіян і почав
ділитися своїми свідченнями про все
побачене але не на судах туди його ще не
запросили А у фільмі Буча який вже за
рік показали у десятках країн Європи
світ должен побачити як это відбувалося
як это відбувається
світ завдяки імена
художнім
фільмом должен почувствовать цю біль
котру переживают українці
і це будуть впливати на політичні
партії там для прийняття дуже важливих
рішень і для нашої країни я в шоці була
того що
комісію ООН не нашла геноциду мне я
просто ну все всю нічні спали думав Ну
от Если би цих людей Вот до цих
братських могил да до тих діточок вбитих
це кіноцит людей вбивали бо вони
українці і Сергій син вбитого мешканця
Бучі Олександра і Тетяна донька
розстріляної Валентини чули про фільм
Буча та ще близько десятка подібних
стрічок в Україні і за кордоном втім
кажуть на душі стане спокійно коли
російські окупанти та їхні керівники
понесуть реальне покарання не у кіно а в
житті Ти дуже хочу щоб ця країна
відповіла за цей злочин
і сам саме такі тяжке розуміння що ти
Люди Да які вони живуть там вони це все
підтримують Тетяна не виключає що вбивці
її матері і так уже можуть бути мертві
вона вірить фінальний акт правосуддя
якого чекають усі українці таки
відбудеться на міжнародному рівні